the box was never to be opened for it
would unleash untold evils upon mankind
but her curiosity could no longer be
contained and she opened the box
cursing humanity forever today we'll be
discussing the myth of Pandora and her
box the story takes place during a
conflict between the gods of Olympus and
the Titans Zeus was furious of the Titan
Prometheus who had stolen the element of
fire from the gods and given it to
mankind as punishment for his actions
Zeus chained Prometheus to a cliff and
every morning an eagle would swoop down
and feast on his liver every night his
liver would heal only for the eager to
return the next morning and feast again
Prometheus torture was not enough for
Zeus he decided he would also punish his
creation mankind for accepting the gift
of fire from Prometheus Zeus ordered the
smyth of the gods
a feast as' to create a woman so
beautiful that she was irresistible to
both gods and men she was modeled on the
goddess of love herself Aphrodite
when her thesis was done do sport her to
life who named her Pandora he had all
the other gods bestow gifts upon her out
of all of the gifts she was given it was
the gift of curiosity from Hera but
would be her downfall
Zeus plan to give Pandora as a gift
Epimetheus Prometheus's brother Pandora
was sent down to earth along with Hermes
who gave her a gilded box the box was a
gift from Zeus and she was told under no
circumstance should she ever opened the
box when Epimetheus first glance at
Pandora he felt instantly in love and
she was to become his bride Prometheus
was aware that Zeus was still seeking
revenge and he warned his brother to
accept nothing from the god Epimetheus
was so enchanted by Pandora he could not
imagine life without her
on their wedding day Hermes came to
Epimetheus and told him that Pandora was
a gift from Zeus a peace offering to
symbolise that there was no longer any
ill feeling between Zeus and his brother
Prometheus Epimetheus believed the words
of Hermes to be true and ignored his
brother's advice every time Pandora
looked at the Box she had to remind
herself that she vowed to never open it
the curiosity that had been gifted to
her by Hera grew each time she denied
open in the box
until one day when she was unable to
resist the curiosity and decided to look
inside of the box
she took the golden key that hung around
her neck and placed it in the keyhole
before she knew it there was a loud
hissing sound and a horrible odor
surrounded the air around her terrified
by what she had just unleashed she
quickly closed the box but it was
already too late
she had released all the wickedness and
evil that Zeus had locked away in the
box and she finally understood that she
was nothing more than a pawn in a game
played by the gods in the Box Seuss had
hidden everything that would plague men
forever sickness death jealousy hatred
famine and passion all began to spread
Pandora began to feel the weight of the
world on her shoulders she felt
responsible for what she had just
unleashed upon mankind not knowing how
to deal with her actions Pandora did the
only thing she could and opened the box
once again she released the one thing
that was left in the box
all of a sudden Pandora felt a warm and
comforting presence and it was at that
moment she knew that everything would be
okay
she had just released the one good thing
that Zeus had trapped in the box just as
quickly as all the evils spread so did
hope from that day on hope would give
humanity the strength to rebuild all
they had lost and rise and succeed at a
time when their existence was coming to
an end in this story Pandora is
essentially the price mankind pays for
the Promethean fire they are given a
task was to let loose all the evils upon
men and destroy Prometheus creation
Pandora serves as a warning to the
destructive properties of humankind's
curiosity sometimes you're better off
not knowing
you may be wondering why Zeus would
place hope in the box if he intended
just the destroy mankind we can only
assume that Zeus his true intention was
never to completely destroy mankind he
felt that the gift of fire gave man an
unfair advantage and so he unleashed all
the evils upon them and if they were to
survive in this time of hardship then
they had earned their existence and I
guess hope was Lucis way of giving
mankind a fair chance
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
[Music]